a female poet Emily days a woman should  receive an education but it should not  be the same as a man maybe they're  scared that if they teach us how the  world works we'll figure out how to take  over I don't know how the two of you fit  into such a tiny bed I don't give up  I have one purpose to become a great  writer there's nothing you can do to  stop me  hey she's so insane of course she's  insane she's Emily Dickinson you need to  cut out these sort of antics all you  have to do something soon desperate  times girl  don't look like you're dead while you're  still alive  if you want something or reach out  you'll be the hauling dickerson they  talk about in 200 years I promise you  that that's a lovely funeral thank you  thank you you might not be better  you  you